i want to take you through what the
latest data is saying uh about covered
knighting because we just had the prime
minister
talking uh about the next step about the
fact that reopening is going to go ahead
on the 19th
of july but the cases are going to get
pretty high
and it's worth just looking at about
that in chart terms to get a sense of
of what we might be staring at in the
next few weeks because it could be quite
dramatic we'll start with this one
there's a reason there's all this space
here which we'll come back to uh in a
second but this is just showing you
cases which is the dark blue line there
and you can see that winter spike
around there kind of two waves in the
winter really but but one in total
and then you've got admission so
hospital admissions those going into
hospital
with covert 19 positive tests and what
you can maybe just about make out
is that those two lines look how
correlated they are through the winter
and now look at how they're diverging so
you've got cases going up very sharply
but emissions
definitely going up uh but not by quite
uh
to such high levels as it was in the
winter
however it is certainly growing and you
get a sense of that really not from
this chart but by taking the same data
and showing it in a logarithmic
axis logarithmic axis really good for
giving you a sense of growth rates
particularly low levels
and particularly with emissions we've
got low levels uh there
but certainly quite a steep growth rate
in fact when you look and the steeper
these lines are the faster the growth
rate really important for exponential
growth and what you can see is emissions
are going up
more or less actually the same angle
certainly in the last week or so
uh as cases so you're talking about
cases doubling every 11 days talking
about hospitalizations doubling
every 11 days as well slightly less
quickly and these things of course are
subject to change that's just the
average kind of growth rate uh each day
in the last
week or so but nonetheless that's quite
a steep growth rate so there is a
divergence that's reassuring
but there is certainly growth as well
and if we just extrapolate those numbers
so we've heard a fair bit about modeling
this isn't a model all it is is taking
recent growth rates and extrapolating
them forward but by the way that's been
a
relatively uh good yardstick for where
we might had uh
through much of covert 19. if you take
that for cases you're talking about
getting up over a hundred thousand cases
uh by the middle of july
uh or towards late july and for
hospitalizations well that dotted line
there shows you
you're getting up towards over a hundred
over a thousand hospitalizations
a day by late july as well potentially
about 2000 depending on how
fast that goes up but of course the big
question is when that growth rate starts
to turn actually it looks like maybe
case growth rate might be starting to
decelerate but it's a bit early to be
too sure about that but nonetheless i
think that you know the big picture is
and what i'll do
is i'll just take the same data and put
it back to a regular chart so no longer
logarithmic this is the kind of chart
that we're more familiar with and well
that's pretty striking isn't it look at
look at case
growth going up towards that hundred
thousand mark higher than we've seen
ever
uh before in terms of certainly daily
numbers some questions of course about
you know what kind of uh tests we're
looking at here but still
incredibly high case numbers whereas
hospitalizations
still you know a fair bit lower than we
saw in that
december january peak you're talking
about more like what we saw around
november
the question though is what happens next
and no one knows how high that would
peak and when you looked at some of
those the modeling that we've seen from
sage and spim
there's such a big difference between
some of the different models we're
talking about some saying it's going to
be relatively low so i'm saying it could
be very high
so we're in a moment of great
uncertainty right now another way of
looking at this
is to look at the lines and just show
you the growth lines uh com
last time around so that's the last time
around hospitalizations really quite
steep line
and then where we are now that red line
there the latest
going up but not going up half as steep
as it was last time around still early
days but nonetheless that looks
relatively encouraging
comparison and then icu so admissions
into intensive care
that's what happened in winter and this
is just showing you once it got beyond a
certain threshold
and each of these is the weeks beyond
that point and then that's the latest so
again
ico admissions still low in comparison
but going up but here's the thing you
know this is why it's going to be
unnerving
we don't really know what's going to
happen next but what we suspect is when
you start to reopen things like
nightclubs you see a spike and why do we
think that well it's pretty obvious you
know all of us can imagine why
but have a look at what happened in the
netherlands recently what we've got here
is just case numbers by different
countries and you can see there's the uk
that's kind of
that's basically the delta strain and
the rising cases in the uk and
you can probably expect that many other
countries one delta arrives there
are likely to see you know relatively
similar growth rates and if we bring on
spain and italy well that's kind of what
you see so there's spain going up quite
sharply
uh recently but just look at the
netherlands i should say netherlands not
italy look at the netherlands
that is going up incredibly sharply not
by maybe kind of 800 percent
uh you're talking about there and what's
happening beneath the surface there is
late june uh the government in the
netherlands i'll just highlight that
late june the government there reopened
nightclubs so 26th of june it was going
to be the 30th but they did it on 26th
of june
reopen nightclubs and then you saw that
spike and you know lots of
anecdotal stories about clusters around
nightclubs uh in the netherlands
netherlands to the extent
uh that just recently they've decided to
temporarily close nightclubs or at least
close them later
earlier in the night so the concern is
you see a further kind of
bit of impetus in case growth if you do
start to reopen
nightclubs which is exactly what the uk
is planning to do
so things are potentially going to get a
little bit nerve-wracking
in the next few weeks in the next few
months because you saw that chart a
moment ago case growth just extrapolated
from where it is now and you're talking
about it getting up to very high levels
almost unprecedented levels
the good news is hospitalizations still
really quite low
but it's going to be a nerve-wracking
few months